welcome to this video a 15 minute game
playing hmm bv 2203 from the netherlands
their name nope maybe it's really am
just turned 50 years old as possible um
oh it's a new account registered no it's
an old account whoops huh sorry to get
rid of this so let's see what do we get
an Enzo on something else okay Adams oh
yeah ok against III I'll try to get the
hook now line leading to complex play
guten aligns with c5 and taking on c3 ok
this is not going to happen 92 its
leading to a different type of position
um yeah my preferred movie is rupee
eight it's slightly mysterious movement
it allows this Bishop retreat all the
way to evade which are always had a soft
spot for I like this kind of setup ok
he's going for d5 himself sound that I
cannot play d5 as black yeah yeah there
are many ways to play mostly d6 and c6
I'm doing that d 6 and then followed by
c6 there's also i can also take on d5
and play c-51 benoni structure
I need to be a bit careful that I don't
yeah it happened to me before that I
went into a benoni structure where he
got in night g34 f3 and I was kind of a
sammich tzimisce by nonius black but
somehow I've lost time with bishop on f8
and later g6 maybe I should just play
something like c6 here and take stakes
e5 maybe maybe but it may be it Scotty
for really sorry if you've got some
noise in the background one of my
neighbors some drilling holes to the
wall that it's terribly annoying maybe I
should if I just take everything on d5
and play 96 this may be not a bad idea
just um if i take Knight takes Knight
takes pawn takes Bishop of three maybe
this is now that's that's very slow from
the white point of view but maybe your
pawn takes i think if i take what the
pawn Knight takes Knight takes Queen
takes 96 and Bishop e6 to come I'm
perfectly okay this is very good
development but if I have take here and
you play something like Bishop f3 I
probably should take here so on Bishop
f3 there is d4 okay it's not even
considering it so
let's take and now we should be six to
come so I have very good development
should I go pee should be six oo hmm
yeah it's not a bad move with just a
question of timing if I maybe have maybe
have something better even there should
be six Queen to be 50 checking be seven
there's a problem I can play 95 in no
not a five-night be three the be three
square is some a good spot for the night
actually let's just consider for a
moment yeah I think this is just okay p
4 9 p-3 it's not bad at all can always
take the c1 bishop
yeah this should be fairly comfortable
yeah maybe I'm even threatening 93 here
it's a very annoying visit of this night
on b3 which makes it difficult time to
even develop the bishop maybe you should
should think about before even before
not be three would be one if I then take
Roxy one is very nicely developed at
least I mean I've got the bishop pair
and so on it's probably all right but
well not so easy for right now what what
you should do
it's it sometimes the problem of white
set up with the 92 3 quickly look at
this it takes lots of time many pawn
moves again a poor move Knight moves
again and so on it's a very slow set up
okay went for before um there is no real
alternative right I'm just thinking
because the queen is a bit a bit off
here like 94 Bishop c4 a 6 if this could
be an idea but the night on c4 is not
really a threatening anything so it's
not clear but it does anything anything
great Queen f6 could be a move Queen f6
the droopy one it does not really help
me much ok I'll go here as it was
intended originally anyway um so what
now okay well I can take 1 C 1 it's not
terrible but still questionable affirmed
there's maybe was still a question if
there is something something better even
I have no way to get rid of this
annoying Queen here right not really
move like rook c8 he can maybe take on
b7 so it's very greedy but probably a
probably a playable okay at the moment
he cannot play Bishop b2 because of 92
this is important and Bishop d2 I simply
take so at the moment he has no no real
developing move available of the bishop
which is Sir the main the main num thing
he needs to address so I have time just
in just a moment of time to try to
improve the position would like to
invade really is it an idea to play
Queen c7 maybe a but then we should be
292 desrook seen one this is really not
helping while the sound is driving me
insane i'm sorry for that but that's not
i wasn't aware when i started the
recording that they would so continue to
do that it it stopped for a while but
now it they commenced doing it i came i
can't play Queen B 6 it's not a bad move
if he takes the a pawn this as a
weakness that I can really attack and
maybe I should do that actually try to
get rid of I mean the queen is most
active piece so maybe it's not a bad
idea to do that next move could be rook
c8 for example and it's not so clear
what his next move is as mentioned it's
it's tricky to to develop
yeah I cannot even close a door or
anything it's just right above me I
think yeah not too sure what is what is
playing now you can play maybe rookie
one this would be M move that improves
this position anyway yeah probably what
I would have played as well okay so
maybe he wants to play Bishop b2 we are
this is very unlikely so if i take here
rook c8 it's going to play Bishop b2 and
then maybe a fire for checking the pawns
could could be an idea the night on be
three sm and it's not clear what it's
doing or should I just take and play
play rook c8 play with the bishop am
yeah that's in fact a very simple
solution the problem is that if he plays
Bishop be too soon my night will be
three does not even have a square okay
I'm doing that of course I like the
bishop pair you you know that but it's
already a question I mean this is this
piece was in danger of being without any
purpose after Bishop b2 okay so should I
take on b5 yeah I guess so and now just
rook c8 keep it simple yeah I think so
yeah this looks quite okay certainly
I've got the bishops but he's got a very
solid structure of course Wow just
something like nitey to to deform acer
is a good plan
I hope your ears haven't fallen off yet
mine are close to do so I'm even trying
to lower the microphone input a bit when
i'm not talking but sir wow yeah nighty
to 2d for this would be a good a good
way to proceed for white I think it's
not terribly active but it's putting the
night on a good square and okay he wants
to put the bishop on a three I guess it
also makes them quite some sense so what
does what should I do now I think I
should take everything off here and rook
c8 this is the easiest the bishop on c8
is also now just protecting the porn yes
it's clear i don't i don't really mind
that hmm okay how to how to activate
this now he can probably go to d5 with
the bishop maybe b6 Bishop d7 something
like that and then I need to I need to
do this anyway getting getting him a way
out for my bishop yes bishop is 70 is
trying to go to d5 probably I seem
ok
hmm maybe he can play it a very
concretely like 93 m intending not to be
five actually never go 869 to a forum
okay then ship da that's it's okay I
don't mind my bishops on the background
gets not a problem I can activate
activate them later okay should I go f5
I think I should really grab some space
now there's even two drills that's quite
amazing how can you do that for for for
this long period of time just drilling
your waltz into holes or whatever okay
so Bishop f6 is 95 m unfortunately okay
okay 95mm 95 Bishop b2 that's 97 which I
forgot IC can play 95 that's a bit a bit
of a problem
yambar should be to 97 s really a
problem I probably need to drop back and
then it meets Bishop if six was pretty
useless yeah well this is this position
I mean obviously I'm on the fan of
having the bishop Pam but this is a very
healthy and active position for wide I'm
not better here probably it's about
equal I don't think white can do much as
well I mean it's not easy to make any
sort of progress in this position well
Arthur no no not really it's probably
equal as as I already mentioned but
don't want to draw I lost the last two
games and I want to try something at
least
it's not easy though not at all if he
moves to c3 I have to shop f6 check so
he needs to retreat again and maybe I
get an A five here this is my idea
trying to exchange at least one of the
porn same
mmm ciao it's not easy not easy for
white knight f4 maybe could be an idea
because I can always just retreat but
not FYI I've gotten our hotel so Bishop
f6 check again okay while King g5
now not easy is he going to play King g5
really it could be kini 5k there any way
to play it more actively for me yeah
king 25 I mean if I play let's say I b6
I mean it looks ugly anyway there's King
you five just going to to grab it
Jim
check okay i'm going to to go for b2
grabbing the queenside if possible
okay but should be too young king d 6
and then Bishop b5 probably yeah okay I
need to go there anyway so no use in
spending time yeah I can take away for
now only wondering it's bishop a three
min maybe even better that's probably
not much of a difference is it shop here
and that's a five threatened I'll take
I'll take come on this is this is easy
easy way to play if for was a bit
strange I also could have played Bishop
c6 actually now that I now that I think
of it mmm now that's maybe what solves a
really good move okay well this is this
is um okay now anyway I guess I'll get
before and then I've got day porn was in
quite successful this exchange for me a4
was a weird move
check
okay check and then the a pawn
why oh why oh why is he not approaching
with the king okay well I five I must do
anyway
yeah maybe I don't even need my own King
to support the pawns the bishop some are
doing it on their own yeah I don't want
want to trade at the moment ready a4 is
going to take no
yeah well anyway this is uses this is
useful anyway getting his King a bit a
bit more off and now a for if I take if
you take I'll take really the point is
basically just promoting from be three
yeah I think it is he cannot take now
the pawn would would promote and if i
take now play a three he's just in time
just in time okay so Bishop situ
probably right or not takes a three
there is a night see one yeah okay this
is also not bad for me but probably not
winning
I will only exchanged a bishop here if
it directly wins other than that I'm not
doing that
not clear what what he does now Bishop
c4 I go a three maybe he plays um night
see one then wow really go ahead and now
he's putting himself into into a self
pin no I'm threatening yeah til morning
takes and Bishop b3 should promote right
there should be three and i'm going to
take next clay day three years as
mentioned i only exchange of it wins
directly and this does win directly i
promote the a porno white resign yeah
very tough endgame I was certainly are
not better in any way at the start at
least he what I really underestimated
him we can look at that when we went to
the end game after after the rook trade
here what I really underestimated was
how quickly his King gets active and I
need I need some time here to to untie
my position this is really a problem
maybe maybe I started played that which
is fine maybe I chose the the wrong set
up right from the start I mean why it is
okay he's not it's not in terrible shape
it's just that I think I probably could
have done something better I'm not not
sure what exactly I mean what we got was
it wasn't even a bit more comfortable
for white around here I this is also of
course a time to honor which doesn't
help it was only getting stranger around
here
after this yeah a for it's just a very
weird move computer wants to take on d6
and give whites a clear give white gives
white a clear advantage which is
surprising I probably have miscalculated
stuff I think yeah I am my idea was that
but he's got a for now ok this is what I
forgot I had I had seen this and now I
have got the idea to play a five I would
even that is not great ok it's not it's
not a terrible problem I mean the
computer here stockfish evaluates ok now
that sets in detail comfortable don't
want to exchange mr. bishops if I got
Bishop AI against night and Bishop with
four against three I have no problem
really this I can who would rather
easily even but yeah oh the other then I
was in big trouble really this was this
was okay now check after the hangman
better I'm better in no way I mean in a
way is the wrong expression I'm better
to what extent i'm not quite sure but
Chad's clear that childlike has no
problems at all and this calling the
shots this is probably winning already
so matter of some precision that he
didn't didn't really have but this this
now then it's basically am yeah maybe i
need to go here but i'm not sure that i
would have done that yes this is this is
okay yeah i think this is a physician
that black should who would relatively
relatively comfortably it's um a case
where the two bishops probably
compensate for the pawn it's not much
fun to play but you should should have
good chances to hold this it's simply
that very often black will be able to
trade down to opposite color
ships want to worship sending that might
be a draw because it's the wrong color
yeah it's a dark color here in the
corner and that is got a light squared
Bishop so probably a good drawing
chances which is not great of course
given the given the fact that around
here I think black is certainly a
comfortable and I shouldn't get into and
Teucer into some trouble yeah i don't i
don't really know maybe it wasn't such a
great idea to trade everything off I
mean it was not necessary to do so maybe
maybe a move like D fire for example
this could could be an interesting idea
or maybe exchange this could be good
maybe a maybe a five this could be an
idea really yeah but he's got this moon
phone it's probably relatively dry ice
also with the pawns traded okay an
interesting game thanks for watching